la siguiente gráfica muestra el
porcentaje de adultos de los estados
unidos de américa que han fumado a
través del tiempo asumiendo que la
tendencia mostrada en los datos ha sido
consistente desde 1945 usa la gráfica
para estimar el porcentaje de adultos
americanos que fumaron en 1945 así que
veamos que está pasando aquí
el eje horizontal dice los años desde
1965 por lo que este punto de aquí
representa 0 años desde 1965 así que
este realmente representa 1965 y vemos
que se ve como si estuviera veamos si
estimar a su valor con sólo verlo
pareciera que está alrededor del 42% de
americanos viendo la gráfica
aproximadamente el 42 o el 41 por ciento
de americanos fumaron en 1965 basado en
esta gráfica
y luego cinco años después este sería
1970 diez años después sería 1975 y
ellos no muestrearon los datos o no
tenemos datos de cada año este es solo
de algunos años lo que es claro es que
tenemos una relación lineal negativa
aquí y no sería difícil ajustar una
línea así que hagamos eso sólo la
aproximar e
e intentaré ajustar una línea a estos
datos así que la línea se ve algo así se
ve como una relación lineal negativa
bastante fuerte y vemos que es una
relación lineal negativa vemos que
mientras el tiempo se incrementa el
porcentaje de fumadores en los eeuu
disminuye y eso es lo que lo hace una
relación negativa y que nos preguntaron
quieren que estimemos el porcentaje de
adultos que fumo en 1945 pues 1945
estaría a la izquierda del cero por lo
que incluso podemos pensar en él como si
1945 estuviera 20 años antes que en 1965
así que déjame ver si puedo dibujar eso
entonces 20 años antes de 1965
veamos esto sería cinco años antes de
diez años quince años veinte años antes
de 1965 así que incluso lo puedo poner
como 20 negativo
- 20 años desde 1965 puede verse como 20
años antes de 1965 por lo que eso
representaría
1945 y una cosa que podemos hacer es de
manera aproximada solo extender esta
relación lineal negativa hacia atrás
y nos dejan hacer eso porque dice que
asumamos que la tendencia mostrada en
los datos ha sido consistente por lo que
la tendencia ha sido consistente esta
línea representa la tendencia así que
solo sigamos yendo hacia atrás
sigamos yendo hacia atrás a la misma
proporción entonces es algo así déjame
me aseguro que se ve igual sirve como si
fuera la misma proporción justo aquí
puedes solo intentar aproximar la veamos
20 años atrás 1945 si extendiera la
línea hacia atrás se ve como se ve como
si alrededor del 52 por ciento de la
población fumara parece parece como si
fuera un 52% en esta parte de aquí
otra manera de pensarlo era de hecho
intentar calcular la razón de descenso y
digamos que lo hacemos para cada 20 años
y eso será útil porque iremos 20 años
atrás así que si vamos 20 años desde
este punto este es 1965
vamos 20 años hacia el futuro eso es
eso es 10 años y esto es esto es 20 años
así que me cambio en la horizontal es de
20 años cuál es el cambio en la vertical
parece que parece que tenemos un
decremento de un poco más del 10% así
que es un decremento del 11 o 10% por lo
que solo diré menos 11
por ciento
ahora veamos si es consistente si
fuéramos a avanzar otros 20 años si
avanzamos otros 20 años se ve nuevamente
como si bajamos como
un 10%
eso es aproximadamente un 10%
si siguiéramos la línea de techo debería
de ser el mismo número así que deja lo
escribo de esta manera
va aproximadamente 10% abajo esa pequeña
línea curva sólo estoy diciendo
aproximadamente menos 10% cada 20 años
menos 10% cada 20 años así que si vas 20
años atrás
si das 20 años atrás deberían
incrementar deberías incrementar tu
porcentaje un 10% por lo que esto debe
de ir arriba o tú debes de incrementar
un 10% así que si empezamos en 41 o 42
una vez más y esto es lo primero que
vimos cuando lo aproximamos deberías
obtener un 51 52% por lo que mi estimado
del porcentaje de adultos americanos que
fumaron en 1945 sería 51 o 52 por ciento